[Music]
and for the past several years I've been
working on our mobility solutions
building all sorts of applications
strategies helping our clients build
applications for themselves and and
their workers and employees and today
I'm here with my colleague Phil Redmond
he'll be joining us on stage shortly and
we're going to be talking about the next
generation of mobile applications
particularly powered by Android and
Google cloud so so with that just to
kind of describe a little bit about you
know what we're seeing where we are apps
you know as we as we've look at them I
mean where they're not new we've been
doing mobile apps for a long time right
probably since the the late 90s really
is when we've been building different
types of mobile applications but over
the years we've seen that the types of
applications we build and the
interactions and the integrations that
we have all of these things are changing
and with the next generation of apps
we're starting to see new technologies
that are being introduced that allow us
to do even more powerful things with
enterprise mobility so we're seeing a
focus more on end-to-end solutions it's
not just about the front end or the back
end or or any one component but we have
to look at it from all of those things
plus cloud plus security right we really
have to look at these as end-to-end
solutions we're seeing that a lot of new
innovation is being driven because of
the advances in technology right so for
the past several years I would say you
know honestly we hadn't really been
innovating in the space of mobile apps
we had been taking things from desktop
and paper and then putting them on
mobile devices but we hadn't really been
doing new things with those mobile
applications and so we'll talk we'll
talk a lot more about that and then in
order to support that there are a lot of
things that need to happen on the
backend side to support those new
applications and then it meant in many
cases you know we don't have access to
data today that we need to have access
to or you know perhaps the backend
systems just aren't able to
support what we need to do and so we
have a number of new types of backing
architectures and platform capabilities
that really enable us to do things in
that space so um here's the agenda real
quick we're going to talk about the
evolution of mobile apps where we were
where we're going look into the next
generation of mobile apps and then talk
about how we're really transforming
those apps in the enterprise and then
some of our recommendations for how to
build next generation applications so if
we look at the over overall timeline of
mobile applications right like I said I
mean this this chart goes to 2005 but in
reality like I said we've been doing
this since the late 90s right I mean you
might remember maybe some of you might
remember you know BlackBerry's and
Windows Mobile devices and Windows CE II
devices and and those types of
applications and so you know we we look
at that time as what we call enterprise
mobility 1.0 and it was all about more
just how do I get email on my devices
how do I get calendar how do I do text
messaging right very simple types of
applications that we were doing and then
you know we started to shift more
towards enterprise mobility 2.0 which is
where we really started to take a more
mobile first approach right so like I
said it wasn't about taking desktop
applications and putting them on mobile
but now we're really looking at what are
those use cases that really apply to
mobile devices to allow us to take
advantage of what's happening on those
mobile devices and so and then we
started to move towards enterprise
mobility 3.0 which is where we are today
but we're shifting into enterprise
mobility 4.0 as well or the next
generation really and enterprise
mobility 300 is more about transforming
how we're doing work today
right it's about introducing new types
of technology is that you know not like
I said it's not about now going to paper
or going from paper to to the phone but
it's about how do we really change the
way our workers do their jobs right and
so we'll show you some examples of how
we're doing that
oh sorry but I also say is you know you
can see here that the the types of
applications that we were building have
evolved over time as well so we've had
mobile websites native apps web apps
hybrid apps right all of this has
changed we still continue to use these
types of applications but we continue to
see new and new types of newer and newer
types of applications evolve and in the
way we interact with the with the data
with our devices that's also changing
right so you know it used to be way back
when we had a stylus and we had to tap
on on you know our device in our app
then we started to be able to use our
finger then it's you know we introduced
gesture so you know you could your the
device could see your eyes moving on the
screen right and then you know taking
advantage of some of the context-aware
capabilities so that the device knew
where we were it knew a little bit more
about the situation the present
situation and perhaps even the past
situation to to provide new ways to
interact with us we're doing a lot more
with voice now right so with the with
the you know emergence of voice
assistants and voice capabilities we're
seeing a lot of voice to text and text
to voice to allow us to interact a
little bit differently and then of
course artificial intelligence which
will we'll talk about a little bit here
as well so you know while there's all
these advancements in these technologies
enterprises are actually quite slow to
adopt these right and if you think about
ourselves in our own everyday use of our
own devices we have and the average
consumer has about 30 applications on
their phones right but if you look at
the enterprise side it's the average is
about eight right and and but it's
growing and it's changing and we're
gonna take a look out at some of the
challenges that are that that are behind
that but the types of applications that
enterprises do use and do buy right we
we consider off-the-shelf or packaged
applications or packaged applications
that might require some level of
customization or some level of
personalization to be to be able to use
them and then on the other side we have
total custom applications right so these
are things these are apps that have been
built from scratch
and so you design the whole experience
you've built everything you know perhaps
using design led thinking or you know
new approaches to designing applications
but they are very custom but you know
when you put that together you can see
that about 70% of the applications that
we're building have some sort of
development required in order to
actually use them right but this but but
going to some of the challenges of why
it's difficult we will talk about some
of these here right so if you look at
the platform challenges we have if you
even if you just look at Android itself
is I'm sure you all know androids got
many different versions right and you
and different features work on different
versions and so we have to account for
those and then you start to introduce
other platforms maybe you're also
supporting iOS or maybe you've got um
you know mobile web and then you really
need to start to understand what can I
do on each of those different platforms
how do I manage that and how do i
account for that that ultimately then
means that you have higher development
costs and operating costs because as you
may know for each of the different types
of applications you have to build that
just requires more development work to
make it happen enterprise's usually have
limited resources and knowledge --is and
knowledge they don't necessarily have
the expertise in security or perhaps
they don't have the right designers or
perhaps they don't have the experts in
the backend integration or security or
even the right front end developers to
be able to build some of the
applications and sometimes business
cases are hard to prove out for many
companies and they can't always
demonstrate the value that they're
getting from the mobile applications and
then when you compare that to the cost
sometimes the cost just outweighs of the
perceived value and the last one there
the the constant kind of tension between
business and IT oftentimes businesses
look to IT and the IT groups can't
support them as quickly as the
businesses might want or perhaps the IT
groups are looking at their businesses
and saying you know what you're trying
to do is really not reasonable or it's
just not possible or maybe it's going to
take a little bit of time because you
know we have to put some things in place
in order to support that right so there
is this kind of challenge
but um you know let's talk about the
next generation of applications and as I
mentioned you know this journey from
mobility 1.0 to 3.0 and I think Google
Maps is a great example of of that and
it's something we can all relate to
right so if we think back to the early
days of Google Maps right you really all
you could do was get directions right
yet to put in an address and it will
give you directions and and at one point
you actually had to print out a list of
the directions because it wasn't
actually navigating you there so then in
mobility 2.0 we started to see things
like navigation and traffic introduced
right then we could plug in multiple
points so it could actually suggest the
right routes and ways to go right and
and things like that so we started to
get a little bit more advanced with
mobility 3.0 now we're really using maps
in a very different way it's not just
about getting directions or figuring out
like how to get somewhere but it's about
exploring places right now when you look
up something you go to maps and you
search you know you'll take a look at
what you know you have reviews you've
got other location information perhaps
you've got hours of business right I
mean there's there's just a lot more
information there you're able to share
now maps is integrated with more things
so even Google assistant is integrated
with map so it knows you know what your
habits are it knows which location is
home or work and it can suggest hey you
have an appointment at this time you
should leave at this time in order to
get there in time right so it's just
really changed the way we're using maps
it's not just about directions anymore
so hopefully you can see how over time
the applications and the technology have
allowed us to build more exciting
applications so you know on the consumer
side right that's it that's a consumer
application but the enterprise
expectations are continuing to increase
because of these really cool consumer
applications that are out there so some
of these for example mobile business
models right I mean the the uber models
or you know the the micro payments or
mobile advertising these are all
capabilities that businesses can take
advantage of and include in their
enterprise solutions as well we expect
these
personalized experiences right just like
how we get in the consumer apps we want
those things for our work applications -
we want to be able to use social media
types of applications and and be able to
share and collaborate with other people
that we work with contextual awareness
our applications should know that
perhaps I did a particular function on
my desktop and now I'm picking it up on
my phone or my tablet or on a different
device and you know taking taking all
that information into account the
payment capabilities and and then the
natural and intuitive interfaces this is
something I think enterprises typically
didn't really focus on this in the past
it was really just you know hey it's for
our employees right they just need
something that works and they didn't
really focus on on that user experience
and then they found that you know their
employees weren't happy with the
applications it just you know they were
complaining about it I was recently at a
pretty major store and they had rolled
out a new mobile application - all
there's you know the cashiers and store
workers and all the all the people like
all their employees were complaining
about this app to me right there's a
customer they're like I can't use this
app it's terrible we can't do like what
we used to do on the other one or you
know I can't figure out like you know
and they were just complaining and you
know that just really shows the
importance of having these really good
interfaces and and designs with our
enterprise applications as well so the
nice thing is that we've got these
really great technologies now that are
allowing us to provide these better
experiences right so voice assistance
we've got we've got Google assistant
we've got Google home we've got dialog
flow to allow us to create conversations
and provide a more conversational type
of experience immersive applications our
augmented reality and virtual reality so
we're able to use AR core and daydream
you know and the SDKs and all that they
provide so that we can again provide
these really exciting experiences
through a AR and VR IOT applications of
course being able to use sensors you
know all around us that we can
communicate with and and provide
additional information or additional
capabilities that we that we didn't have
before we mentioned the context aware
machine learning and AI think this is
one of the most exciting places and
favori was talking about that as well
but you know we're now building in
capabilities such as natural language
processing image recognition right
prediction all of these capabilities to
allow us to to make our apps smarter and
then instant apps which Phil will show
us a demo about but it's really being
able to take action at that point of
desire rather than having to you know to
go and download applications and find
out where in the application you need to
go but these are just instant functions
that we can do right away so a lot of
advancements on the device itself right
if you think about the smart phones that
you all have just look year after year
and all the changes that you see right
in terms of device processing time where
you know now we've got multi-core
processors that can be two two and a
half times faster than single core
processors right that allows us to do
the AR and the VR and the machine
learning on the devices especially the
edge analytics type of work that we can
do as well the screens and the cameras
you know every year there's this kind of
competition to see who has the better
camera right it and and it's always you
know about us taking selfies and
pictures but the cameras and the screen
resolution really allow us to get much
more accurate and precise with things
like image recognition or a RvR right
and so it allows us to to do a lot more
with that information the sensors we
talked about you know as well
fingerprint sensors accelerometers you
know ambient light sensors right and so
on and then wearables as well right we
we have a wide variety of whether it's
watches or glasses or any other number
of wearable devices that allow us to
have a much better experience and so as
you look at all of these right the nice
thing with Android is that you have a
variety of devices and form factors and
price points right so enterprises can
pick the right device that meets their
needs and and matches what they're
trying to do all right so some examples
of some of the the technologies that are
providing these experience
says we've already talked a bit about
context-aware and how our applications
can adapt to our environment or to our
situation or or to whatever it might be
the AI powered applications right again
are our applications are getting smarter
they're learning more about all sorts of
things right they're taking advantage of
a lot of data that we hadn't had before
getting into recommendations into
personalization and so on self learning
application so this is about the app
learning itself and how it can take
different actions based on what it's
experiencing and and what it's been
learning over time and edge analytics
this is the ability to you know you may
be familiar with tensorflow and cloud ml
and and these kinds of image recognition
capabilities that we've been doing for a
few years right but that's in the cloud
and now we can actually do these things
with tensorflow Lite and you know some
of the neural networks api's and things
like that we can do it right on the
device we don't even need to go to the
cloud and so that allows us to do things
in more real-time and and just get a
much better experience in that way which
is really exciting
IOT based applications right I mean
we're seeing a lot we're seeing lots of
examples of those you can see those in
healthcare you can see those in retail
you can see those in manufacturing and
so on where we're really trying to take
advantage of the sensors and and the
other machines that are around us to to
provide a better experience immersive
applications voice assisted templatized
templatized application we list this
here but I haven't really seen a lot of
success with those that's really where
third-party providers might provide a
template type of an application which
you you know with build off of and and
perhaps some you know customize a lot
more than the normal but you know many
many have tried it but it's just not as
successful for them from some of what
I've personally seen okay so now I'm
gonna transition it over to Phil and
Phil will come and first you are our
first demo with our voice based digital
system
great great can you hear me okay thank
you Nisha I'm Phil Redmond I'm part of
our digital transformation team and so I
work with clients globally to help them
around mobility security big data and
analytics AI and machine learning and of
course mobile technologies and so we're
working with clients to help transform
what they're doing and here's an example
of one that I'll show you is what the
organization called West Midlands Police
they're the second largest police force
in the UK so over 10,000 police officers
just a bit smaller than the London
police force the London metro and
they're really looking on how to
modernize the police force going forward
and using mobile devices specifically
Android mobile devices and so we worked
with them to get an understanding of how
we can add um accommodate police
officers as they're you know going
towards different incidences and how to
support them when they get to those
instances so we're going to show you an
example of what that looks like and
we've created what we call you know part
of a digital virtual mobile system now
as you might be familiar with virtual
assistants and there's lots of varieties
here but it's an idea of more of a voice
based interaction for the police
officers obviously in many cases police
officers will be in their cars they may
be by themselves they may not have you
know hands to be able to navigate
information at the same time they want
to find out information when they're on
the move they don't have a lot of time
once they get to what they call an
incident right to find out that
information so we work together with
them in order to understand how they can
better these better supported by having
information at their hands and
understanding what's going on as they
arrive and then improves on the
processes that they have once they
arrive - all by using the digital
virtual assistant so it's just like we
may use a digital virtual assistant like
Google assistant or Siri in order to
help us you know with our tasks for
taking messages or making phone calls or
doing searches they're looking to see
how they can use voice based digital
assistants also in their work so I'm
going to switch it over to the
chromecast now
we put up on the screen
can you see the chromecast
is it casting
that's right make sure I thought
well what's it canceled up there there
we go so as you can see when we worked
with them we didn't want to give them a
typical kind of Android app that may be
part of the material design features
that they might be used to we wanted to
give them something that was very type
of voice oriented so you can see there's
no soft keys that we have here for
navigation they can completely navigate
by voice now we did give them an
opportunity by using the sliding menu to
be also navigating but we didn't give
them any buttons on the side here in
order to navigate and so they're easily
able to hear information as you can see
here these this is an incident that they
might be seeing right these are of
course made-up incidences but these are
incidences they might be seeing and so
simply by pushing on them they can hear
the information now when they get a
report they may not just get one report
they may get additional information as
they're going so you can see here
there's all different types of
information that might be coming on but
I simply just pushing on this I don't
think you could hear it
right click on but do not disturb that
might be the reason why can you hear it
gather witness statement location ha
zero one a crumbly London - face number
- one hundred twenty eight thousand
seven hundred eighty one spout area for
CCTV footage location SW 13 nine 5 ounce
low London - so you can see how the
digital information keeps coming out
they can hear all the updates all right
so that's one thing to do they could
also navigate the application so if they
wanted to make a phone call just like
with a regular assistant they could push
our little button here go to blue K
pages sorry I didn't get that go to blue
pages okay showing the blue pages so
they can either go to their directory
that they have here they can call up
someone's name they can say call or
message etc the other thing we wanted to
do was give them a advance capability
for taking witness statements so today
they take all their witness statements
in the analog way with basically a
pencil and paper right and so those may
not be accurate now we can start a new
witness statement here start a new
witness statement okay here's a new
witness statement and by simply on
pushing the icon they can start
retrieving the information from the
witness and it takes the notes right for
them in the statement which they can go
and which they can go and then oh we
show up there we go may be a little
noisy in here but they can take the
notes right on the witness statement and
then go and edit them later alright so
you can see that comes up we can also
integrate this into Google Translate and
so that there's another language that's
someone speaking they came then
translate it onto English right there
now today they still need to actually
print out the witness statements and get
them signed so they can't use this for
court but it gives them an accurate way
of collecting the data much more
accurate than it was with pencil and
paper so some pretty cool stuff using a
digital virtual assistant you know for
the police force
alright could we switch back to the
presentation now please
so as you know there are some standard
ways that we've been developing mobile
apps for many many years you know and we
get asked this quite a bit you know
what's the best way from our clients
what's the best way that we should
develop our mobile apps what technology
what platforms should be using and a lot
of it goes into you know who's the app
being used for is it for the customer is
it for their employees is it with a
partner what platforms are they using
are they single are there multiple
platforms in many cases the majority of
applications especially for customers we
developed still in the native format
right and so most applications today are
still using the native capabilities
whether in the Android SDK right or for
for Apple right it gives them the
breeches type of interface that they can
have high levels of security right it's
something that everybody wants to do
today typically for their customers and
when you have a large number of users
that will be using that app it makes a
lot of sense but for internal users it
may not make us much sense because you
have a smaller internal employee force
to develop that app and there actually
may be and what we see in most cases
multiple platforms that are supported
within the enterprise space so they may
support both Android and and an apple
capabilities and so they're looking at
building more of a a native app I'm
sorry a hybrid app that you know has
kind of the best of both worlds for
native and web a single development
platform to support the applications
that they have obviously they're you
know as an advantage is the operating
pieces on that the testing the
development and then the operating costs
are much lower because you don't have to
support individual applications and
individual platforms and so we're seeing
an increased demand from our customer
base to support more of these hybrid
apps and that's across a different
number of different hybrid development
technologies mobile web is an early way
of people for developing apps web-based
apps but they have been very responsive
and so obviously you need a good
connection you don't have a realign
capability they are OSI agnostic but the
interface and the the usability of those
typically are a lot lower and so we
don't really build a lot of mobile web
apps you're just not really demanded
right but we think that there are
opportunities for this to change in the
future which kind of more of the next
generation of mobile apps that we're
going to focus on including get this
didn't work
progressive web apps micro apps and
instant Maps does anyone here have any
experience with progressive web apps at
all raise your hand just one person
right so been around for a little bit
introduced not too long ago but I've
been around for a bit where you could
take the benefits of native and increase
capability for mobile web apps right so
these are web apps you can put your
there instantly shareable there linkable
you can send someone a link you don't
need to download these from an app store
and they have a functionality that's
improved performance overall for for
mobile users okay and so we see
certainly I'm playing around with some
of these different capabilities only
supported on Android today not supported
on iOS but we think that these could be
some interesting ways of improving some
of that experience for mobile web apps
and it gives a much lower cost for
development and lower operating costs
overall micro apps are another way that
we think that are expanding so micro
apps are highly targeted apps very
application specific apps very simple to
use they may live and sit right on the
desktop they have a very limited amount
of functionality an example of a micro
app maybe something like weather for
instance or you can see in the future
where maybe uber would put out on my
crap where all you do is just push the
button right and in five minutes your
car shows up right so think about that
like you know if you're familiar was
kind of the Amazon buttons where you
just push it and you know your case of
water shows up you know a day or two
later the same thing for mobility just
push the button and you get the
information so very very low cost
developed very low cost to use I mean
even today we've seen their apps and
native apps have grown in complexity
where they have so many windows and
screens and clicks in order to get the
information and mobility is all about
the here and the now it's about how to
do that much quicker and easier and you
can't get quicker and easier than a
micro app which can deliver the
information or the service you know ASAP
and then finally we're going to show you
and talk a little bit about these
instant apps
does anyone familiar with instant apps
introduced a few years ago not too many
people here so an instant app or app
functions that are launched launched
without downloading an app right so it's
a bit a web-based app now you know built
in native sorry native capabilities
right but they can leverage those native
capabilities but make it much easier to
develop it much quicker and I'll show
you some examples of what we mean by
that right they are fairly limited but
there
very very easy to use and to deploy so
they're great if you're only using the
app on a one-time basis or for a
short-term temporary basis
so today even for things like these
conferences you know we may download the
conference app and we use it for the
week but do we really need to have it
sit on our device right how many people
here have downloaded after they've used
only temporarily or for one-time use and
then deleted it off their device with
instant apps you won't you won't have to
do that anymore
right again only available for for
Android platforms so I'm going to show
you kind of what that means if we go
back to the chromecast this is a native
app that we developed for a client for a
package delivery service last year this
is a full native app that lives on the
device and a package delivery service
you have people that are scanning
packages in putting them on trucks and
then you have people that are delivering
the packages now sometimes that's the
same person but oftentimes it's a
different person so the driver who's
driving and delivering those packages
would get this app but they might not do
any scanning it's a woman you log into
this app right you can see here there's
an ability that they could just click on
here and they can scan packages in right
so if we have my little barcode reader
here it reads the barcode it scans the
package you get the information in but
this is a full native app including
turn-by-turn directions and instructions
that we have built on on Google and
Android platform right completely out of
Google firebase on the back end on the
front end we have Google Maps in here we
have image recognition all different
types of capabilities for this but for a
person who's just scanning it do they
really need to have this full type of
application so I have another device
here I'm gonna bring this one up
and this is going to show you a instant
app that we developed that kind of does
the same thing
all right and so let's say the package
scanner comes into work we can send them
an email so just through this email
right here you can see they get a link
right
no downloading anything from App Store
no pushing anything out simply click on
the link and an instant app will open
right up right they could just log in
with their credentials and then BOOM
start scanning in seconds right the same
type of idea very very low cost to
develop very easy to do and then boom
when they're done they just click out of
the out of the app and then they're done
they can save the link for the future
whatever that is and so we can send them
a link every morning they can put it in
their calendar so very easy to use so
you can imagine a plethora of different
ideas of how you can use these Android
instant apps for potential temporary use
or for a short-term use or for people
don't need a full app capabilities so so
you know not a lot of this being used in
the marketplace yet but we see a whole
lot of interest and we think that a
whole lot of capabilities to come out
with us all right we can go back to the
presentation now please so those are two
examples of us working with clients and
developing and using some of these new
generation technologies the first one
using capabilities like machine learning
and AI so with the natural voice
recognition you can see how easily that
worked even within the conference halls
here when it's noisy natural natural
language speech all those types of
things that we can use you know using
the Google technologies right so
capabilities are simplifying in many
ways but they're offering more
capabilities so with these micro apps
right some examples here simply you know
maybe ordering something off a menu
approving a vacation request approving a
TN a different micro flows so
integration now into enterprise
application platforms like
salesforce.com or workday and ServiceNow
so capabilities of supporting that not
just you know a web-based capability but
integrated into really robust
information and then micro services so
as we all know micro services are
growing in demands to incorporate more
support and capabilities across these
different types of devices so what is
this take in order to support a lot of
these next gen app capabilities
heard about some stuff on the front end
right so we have hardware software
networking bilities that have evolved to
support a much richer capability for
these mobile apps so the bottom line is
we feel with our clients there's no
excuses anymore right there's nothing
holding us back
even costs have come down costs of
hardware for services for cloud
capabilities right there's really very
few barriers to do almost anything out
there today except for there's an issue
of back-end right well we run into all
the time is back-end complexity so
depending on the industry they could be
a regulated industry they could be an
industry that's been around for a long
time they don't have api's that are
developed and they don't have an easy
way of accessing their corporate data
right if we could just erase everything
from our clients and start over the
world would be much simpler but it'd be
a very very expensive place to go and so
how do we access that data for them to
put it on to these kind of front-end
capabilities that we're talking about so
we're not only thinking about that
front-end development but also the
backend and there's lots of cool stuff
that's happening on the back end to make
this all work
so we're going from you know kind of
monolithic structures which have been
easy to deploy ease know scalability
issues but difficult to add features
right to much more scalable right with
client server capabilities and now into
more micro services and so a micro
service is a platform right and an
architecture software architecture that
can easily integrate into business
services and it can break down the
different application needs into these
different services that you can easily
build once and then use across all
different types of mobile platforms so
you can eliminate a single point of
failure because if one let's say
business service goes down there's still
other services that would be available
there isn't one level of integration
they're very very scalable and most
importantly they're reusable right so we
could build stuff for some clients and
then we can reuse those micro services
across different clients very easy very
fast very very low cost to build these
services they're very very rich too so
they can support complex orchestration
across different data stores across
different platforms across different
types of mobile devices across different
data types so very very very complex
stuff that's built down and integrated
very easily and they use this business
logic layer as a service it's a new
digital orchestration layer that we
think that's really important that's
evolved in
the mobile backend as a service
capability right
so going from monolithic to more modular
capabilities so we can take these
different services and drop them in
place and customize those for different
types of employees for different types
of customers for different types of
needs on the go again using the
front-end capabilities of instant apps
progressive web apps and micro apps etc
right they flow across all those
different capabilities so we can we can
customize whatever those employee needs
are whatever the mobile needs are to the
back-end capabilities right instead of
you know having to build that out each
time right that's what we really have to
do today we typically have to build
something specialized out each time
right and that's very very time
consuming and very very expensive and so
are we going from you know 12 to 24
months to build these things out we can
do these in a matter of days in many
cases so very very rich and very very
awesome capabilities right this also
doesn't exclude any of the intelligence
that these next-generation apps need
right so whether the apps need to be
deployed when they don't have context
they can't see the back-end capabilities
and/or they're very limited in what they
can see you're right now we can add in
that back-end and that intelligence same
intelligence that we may see on more
richer apps we could even do that on
these basic apps - we can support
connected capabilities on app services
so there's a common framework that
integrates you know these disconnected
backends and we can support them offline
real time configuration of any type new
events or engagements or anything that
comes out all doing that on the flow on
the go and so as you may be familiar
with a lot of this is done through a
mobile as a back-end system is anyone
here familiar with Ambassador mobile as
a back-end system if you raise your hand
oh okay not too many people surprisingly
these things have been out for a long
long time in over six seven years and
the idea was that this mobile as a
back-end system would be a mobile will
be a platform that does two things one
would be a very quick and easy
development that works across all
different types of mobile platforms so
you can develop a mobile front-end
typically in a hybrid app capability
right to support any type of platform
whether it's Android whether it was
blackberry whether it was Apple right so
easy way to develop the second part of
it was though wasn't easy and
raishin so api's built right into the
application a mobile backend piece that
was integrated into your business
services okay to be able to support and
get the data from your back-end onto
these mobile devices very easy and very
chilly right so like I said this has
been around for a while as you can see
nobody here has been using them and we
don't see a whole lot of use in them yet
because I know they're having some
challenges on the backend basically the
front-end hasn't been very rich on there
was still more development that needed
to be done on those front ends in order
to make them work and so again most
people have been kind of focusing on
consumer applications and going straight
to that kind of front-end development
and native application development but
what we see here is with the emergence
of the micro services we can add in a
new layer to increase the capabilities
what we're calling this digital
orchestration layer to an existing
mobile backend service to start
supporting those micro services that I
mentioned before so then a very very
quick way and very low cost like whether
it's a native app whether it's a web app
a hybrid app to support the backend
capability so it's going to bring in a
lot more intelligence and a lot easier
to develop and and such and so obviously
this does increase the number of api's
that the organization may need to build
out in order to support those different
services but we believe that this will
be a much faster and easier way and
maybe more successful way of kind of you
know getting these applications out into
the hands getting the data out into the
hands of the mobile workers as Nisha's
said right we have all these
technologies and capabilities and the
consumer world has really grown
dramatically but the enterprise world
has still been very limited in support
for a lot of the data and so for these
next-generation app services we want to
look at B you know things to think about
in the future our support for more
liquid apps right so liquid has become a
term that's fairly popular out there but
what we mean with this is much more
agile apps right so apps that can be
changed on the fly where new data can be
brought in where they can be updated on
the fly so we don't want to think of
these apps as just static right every
time there's an update we know that we
to the OS we need to change some of
those apps so what's a better way of
doing that versus kind of rewriting the
whole app or I'm having the patch those
apps all the time so we have to think of
new ways to support these kind of liquid
apps connected app services are another
huge consideration when it comes down to
the app capabilities so we want to look
at the difference
services so the backend capabilities
whether there are intelligent app
services the s you know salesforce.com
capabilities or ERP whatever that might
be out there so how can we support these
different services and add context to
that so I knows my location just like we
show it on the map with you know
enterprise Teredo it knows where we're
standing on the map so Brett can
recommend you know coffee for us or you
know other things that we might want
during our day can we do the same thing
for the enterprise so example is that is
one of our clients wanted to be able to
build in intelligence services to their
salesforce.com
that showed them on the map where their
customers are and then be able to kind
of look into those customer base and see
what are the recent sales or even using
machine learning to make recommendations
of new opportunities to self in that
customer you know and so of course most
salespeople have a schedule and they
have a calendar that they're following
during the day but we also know that
meetings get cancelled or they may find
some more time during the day so what's
the easiest way to kind of find out how
to optimize that downtime right so this
whole idea of assisted selling is huge
now by simply like looking onto the map
by seeing where the customers are
finding customer information right
they're able to then make
recommendations and then potentially you
know do additional revenue that they
hadn't thought up during the day before
so lots of intelligent app services that
we see are being built into these apps
now of course with those capabilities
lots of API calls are going to need to
be made right so they need to have high
performance app services that can scale
right so we test out for those apps all
the time but that's going to be a huge
consideration because there could be
more and more data coming whether it's
from the cloud whether it's from
on-premise on the enterprise wherever
that may be
lots of API calls that are going to be
made during the day it needs to be
digital ready right and so that means
how can we use analytics in order to
improve you know whatever the
application may be how can we improve
the interface how can we improve the
mobile experience how can we make sure
that security although is strong but it
doesn't become a barrier to use of these
different apps and so digital ready is a
huge piece on that and then as I
mentioned with the new digital
orchestration services right how can we
make sure that we have the right api's
that are easily built into those apps
for today and in the future you know do
any mourner improve those services and
add services on to make them ready to go
in the future
so some key recommendations and then we
can take some questions right so we
think around these next-generation apps
right they're not just aligning to your
digital strategy and the transformation
and most organizations right but they're
going to become a big part if not a big
you know be part of their digital
transformation strategy you know a lot
of the data and the traffic as you see
has already moved off of desktops and
moving on to mobile devices and so this
has to fully align and really help drive
a lot of transformation strategy right
also put a strategy together to help you
know modernize your app architectures
and so the best thing that we see on
this is that it's no longer siloed
between your mobile device between your
portable devices and then of course
between your you know your laptop or
your desktop devices that mean being
used you know a lot of these
capabilities can go across any of those
different platforms and so it's a
write-once
work anywhere type of scenario right
which builds a big integrated approach
and helps reduce the time for
development and reduce the cost in the
future and so when we're doing this
strategy for our clients we're not
looking at mobility as a standalone
capability we're looking at as as part
of the solution on how to take data from
one area to the next from one device to
the next and how to how to just think
about the data access and not think
about the device or the network we don't
have to worry about that as much anymore
right and then there's always going to
be the support for multiple ecosystems
so there are gonna be new ecosystems in
the future that maybe we're not thinking
about but we want to make sure that it's
something that we can easily apply and
move in the future where today we're
building out and customizing and
integrating a lot of capabilities
because of these monolithic systems that
we've had in the past
of course which weren't digital ready
which weren't designed for mobility
right but think about in the future you
know there could be different types of
devices so we showed more and more
interest we showed devices around
wearables for instance and so we see
more and more interested wearables for
sure whether that's something that you
wear on your wrist or nurses you know
can wear wearables on around their neck
or we're working with a cruise line that
wants to put wearables and and get rid
of keys right in car keys and so it
becomes more and more part of what
people are using so there could be
different devices different Hardware
pieces that people are using so
different types of ecosystems and you
know that building customized apps
doesn't go away
so as we mentioned you know there's a
small percentage today of off-the-shelf
app development it's only around 30% of
apps today are purely just off-the-shelf
so the majority the vast majority takes
some customization all right the idea
with the templatized apps that Nisha
talked about was that there would be you
know 80% of the work done with 20%
customization it turns out you know it's
a lot more than that needs to be done so
there's always customization that needs
to be done
right so we're not ever going to get
away from that but you can see there's
different ways to customize and we don't
look at everything the same way anymore
so now when we walk into our clients we
can figure out what the requirements are
first and then decide okay is it a
native app is it a web-based app it'll
be a hybrid app or you know some of
these micro apps and instant apps you
know are also options that we can use
and so we're not just building a one
size fits all for our clients we have
different ways depending on the
requirements of their speed what their
budget might be what the application
requirements are their users the devices
that they're using right and so we're
building a whole different types of
different systems for them and we're
doing that intelligent way like I
mentioned you know almost everything
we're doing today especially out of our
team with digital transformation
includes includes machine learning right
whether it's voice based capability so
moving away from you know navigating the
app through the finger and all through
voice and we think that's something
that's going to grow in the future and
I'm we've seen great responsiveness and
great capabilities across these devices
for using this so we think something
like that is going to become where the
future of these different apps so we're
thinking about navigation we think about
the development you know lots of changes
that are happening in these applications
today and that will be continuing we
have a mobile point of view or a point
of view in a white paper that goes into
a lot more detail on this and if you
want to give me your business card I'm
happy to send you the link to that and
you can get more detailed information
both on the front end and the back end
development to kind of walk away with
this and then of course the slides will
be available and this will be available
on YouTube later today so thank you very
much for your attention we have a few
minutes left to take some questions you
should come back up any questions out
there if you do please come up and speak
in the microphone because we're being
recording for for all this for posterity
later yeah I just I did just want to add
I mean hopefully you've seen throughout
this presentation that you know how we
really truly are moving to this next
generation of applications and it's
because of all the hardware chain
the software changes on the device side
but also what's happening in the backend
and all the new capabilities that are
available to us and you know Phil and I
we we both work on our Google
partnership team and three years ago
more than three years ago we started
working with the Android team and it was
all about how do we how do we do more
with Android in the enterprise and you
know one of the things we've really
touched upon and talked about was that
Google really does have that end-to-end
technology stack and that is their real
differentiation that that they have and
so whether it's the devices whether it's
Android or the wearables or the glasses
or the connected devices whatever there
might be to the backend machine learning
you know the the image recognition of
course the cloud infrastructure and
everything that's needed there to
support these applications we really do
get a nice seamless and really exciting
experience and we've got lots of great
examples that we can tell you about
further all right well we're here if if
you guys need us and thank you very much
for for joining and for listening thank
you
[Applause]
[Music]